[Música]
bienvenidos a este enlace andino desde
ecuador en esta emisión hablaremos de la
crisis carcelaria que contabilizó 300
privados libertad asesinados tan sólo en
el año 2021 también comentaremos de la
despenalización del aborto en el país
andino donde la asamblea nacional deberá
aprobar un nuevo texto legal que obliga
a los servicios de salud a ofrecer
atención médica a mujeres víctimas de
violación y para terminar iremos hasta
el archipiélago de galápagos donde
recientemente el ecuador ha creado la
nueva reserva de protección biosfera que
se convertirá en el mayor corredor
marino de américa uniendo a cuatro
países
en promedio un recluso es asesinado cada
día en las cárceles ecuatorianas el año
2021 representa el histórico de
violencia más trágico del sistema
carcelario del país 300 privados de
libertad murieron asesinados de ese
total 286 personas perdieron la vida en
4 masacres durante los meses de febrero
julio septiembre y noviembre
ecuador cerro del año 2021 con un
promedio de 13 homicidios por cada
100.000 habitantes en los centros
penitenciarios la seguridad en las
cárceles es uno de los principales retos
del estado la peor cifra de violencia
carcelaria en los últimos 10 años
inferior a la tasa promedio de américa
latina de 17 casos pero muy por encima
del promedio mundial de 5,8 según cifras
oficiales el presidente de la república
guillermo lasso reconoció no tener el
control de las cárceles los principales
problemas que enfrenta el sistema son el
hacinamiento la falta de infraestructura
personal presupuesto y agilidad de los
trámites judiciales una comisión de
diálogo y pacificación fue declarada por
el presidente de la república para
reducir la credibilidad e intentar
pacificar las cárceles del país durante
seis meses intentará sanear el
debilitado sistema de rehabilitación
penitenciario mientras oscuro el
saneamiento o familiares de los presos
piden soluciones más rápidas
seamos tratados más que no sea así que
le mantenga o que le tenga un buen
estado no que haya más de atención
que le buena atención en la comida en
todo que en la salud
ahora abordaremos la despenalización del
aborto en ecuador durante el mes de
enero de 2022 la asamblea nacional
intentará aprobar un nuevo texto que
obliga a los servicios de salud ofrecer
atención médica a mujeres víctimas de
violación la comisión que elabora la ley
propone que el aborto se aplique en un
plazo máximo de 28 semanas para mujeres
mayores de edad y sin con un plazo para
menores de edad o mujeres con
discapacidad
grupos feministas y pro-vida han vuelto
a concentrarse en las puertas del
parlament o se manifiestan a favor y en
contra del texto de ley que deberá ser
debatida y aprobada por la asamblea
nacional el proyecto será de obligatorio
cumplimiento por tanto de operadores de
salud y establecimientos públicos y
privados para prevenir la violencia
contra las mujeres
es ilógico pensar limitar si quieres
algo que ya es de excepcional la causal
en sí para acceso al aborto es
excepcional en este caso lo que nos dice
la causal violación es que sólo las
mujeres niñas adolescentes y personas
constantes víctimas de violación son las
que pueden acceder a un aborto me
entiendes no es que el resto de mujeres
podemos imponer si quieres a este grupo
de población que ya tiene que cumplir
con una determinada característica me
entiendes para poder acceder mayores
limitaciones como un plazo es inadecuado
la temporalidad del embarazo para su
interrupción fija la atención en las
calles por ello preguntamos a los
ciudadanos y esto fue lo que expresaron
bueno nosotros no somos nadie para
juzgar a quien tenga la decisión de
poder abortar o que tenga o que no tenga
los recursos necesarios para poder
[Música]
mantener a un bebé oa un niño pues razón
bueno yo estoy a favor del aborto yo no
estoy de acuerdo con la aprobación de
este proyecto porque yo soy de la idea
que el único que tiene
la potestad de quitarnos de darnos la
vida es así nada más que esto ahora
hablaremos en la nueva zona de
protección marina recién creada el
archipiélago de galápagos que contará
con 190 mil kilómetros cuadrados que
servirán para garantizar un océanos
saludable que capturar a mayores niveles
de carbono y liberación de oxígeno para
mitigar la crisis climática una nueva
oportunidad para el planeta de preservar
sus especies marinas de ataques
indiscriminados a través de un decreto
interinstitucional
ecuador forma parte de la nueva ruta
para la protección marina de las
especies migratorias que navegan las
aguas y que funcionarán desde las islas
galápagos hasta la isla del coco y costa
rica será el mayor corredor marino del
hemisferio occidental libre de pesca
donde convergen especies en peligro de
extinción 60 mil kilómetros cuadrados
reservas biosfera el decreto también
contiene el mayor canje de deuda del
mundo a cambio de conservación ambiental
cuyo objetivo será declarar la ante la
unesco como zona de reserva biosfera al
planeta un corredor marino el este
tropical se suma a la actual reserva de
130 mil kilómetros cuadrados de aguas
protegidas que buscan mitigar la crisis
climática
einsten dos estudios por los que en los
que nos hemos basado para hacer esta
nueva reserva marina en la que luego
detallar especies para guiarle hace el
agro de ponerle unos aparatos
satelitales a estas especies
hemos comprobado que ellas eligen los
montes submarinos
como rutas migratorias como rutas de
reproducción como rutas de navegación de
estas especies marinas no objetivo de
pesca lobo marino mantarraya tiburón y
demás especies que navegan en estos
montes submarinos
delegaciones de colombia costa rica
panamá y ecuador acordaron el mayor
corredor marino el pacífico este
tropical luego de cinco meses de diálogo
pescadores artesanales y la flota
pesquera industrial una propuesta
anunciada en la con 26
hasta que esta edición del ascendido
desde ecuador les invito a seguir con la
programación de france 24 en español
gracias por acompañarnos hasta la
próxima